peu après 18h les magistrats de la cour
d'appel de bordeaux décidé que maurice
papon devrait se constituer prisonnier
avant l'examen partir du 21 octobre
prochain de son pourvoi en cassation ils
ont donc rejeté sa demande de dispense
pour raisons de santé malgré ses 89 ans
si maurice papon n'obtempère pas sa
condamnation à dix ans réclusion
criminelle pour complicité de crimes
contre l'humanité sera définitive
commentaires tirer curtet avec david
glazier à bordeaux quelques minutes
avant la décision de la cour d'appel de
bordeaux
les parties civiles sont stoïques calme
17 ans de bataille juridique leur ont
appris la patience et cette étape est
sans doute l'une des dernières dans
quelques instants
la justice va obliger l'ancien préfet à
se constituer prisonnier avant l'examen
de son pourvoi devant la cour de
cassation
c'est son ultime recours
ok de maurice papon est rejeté nous
avons la satisfaction malgré le fait que
les parties civiles soient déclarées
irrecevables d'avoir pu par notre action
faire en sorte que la justice soit égale
pour tous nous sommes soulagés
il faut croire que nous avions quand
même 17 ans d'obstination et de combat
cette affaire viennent à point car en
définitive c'est chaud que j'ai
développé constamment papon n'est pas un
homme invalide un invalide et sur un
fauteuil roulant un invalide et un grand
handicap et ce n'est pas le cas de papon
maurice papon lors de sa dernière
apparition publique paraissait fatigué
mais toujours combatif
la cour d'appel de bordeaux n'a pas
suivi les réquisitions qui demandait une
expertise médicale sur l'état de santé
de l'ancien préfet telle était pourtant
les arguments de la défense
c'est un échec pour la justice alors
qu'il existe un droit dans le code de
procédure pénale de dispenser le
condamné d'entrée en prison la veille
l'examen de son pourvoi roux n'a le
droit d'en être dispensé la justice
contre 1 donc maurice papon à entrer en
prison le 20 octobre prochain
mais ce soir son avocat laissent encore
planer le doute sur les intentions
définitive de son client dominique
verdeilhan comment expliquer une double
décision du sist première
la cour d'assises il comparaît libre et
puis là on lui demande de retourner en
prison
eh bien écoutez la situation juridique
de maurice papon n'est plus la même en
octobre 97 la cour d'assises remet en
liberté après trois jours passés en
prison
un accusé des magistrats ont jugé deux
ans plus tard la donne est différente
une condamnation qui certes n'est pas
définitive a été rendue au nom du peuple
français
on ne juge plus on applique la décision
de la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de bordeaux n'est pas
susceptible de recours alors en dehors
des arguments juridiques ordonné à
maurice papon d'aller en prison est
riche en symboles parce que maurice
papon et est devenu un cas d'école une
exception condamné mais libre des
magistrats par les e mails une
jurisprudence papon et dans l'opinion
publique subsistait l'étrange sentiment
qu'un homme poursuivi pour crimes contre
l'humanité avait été condamné à dix ans
de prison avec sursis
est ce qu'il va se passer d'autres
j'irai d'autres éléments de l'action
judiciaire d'ici le 21 octobre dégoter
maurice papon peut faire un choix ne pas
se constituer prisonnier mais alors son
pourvoi ne sera pas examiné sa
condamnation deviendra définitive il
aura simplement fait reculer l'échéance
disons simplement que les avocats ne
m'en laisse papon pense à une autre
carte qu'ils ont dans leur jeu et qu'il
pourrait sortir après l'examen du
pourvoi en cassation
une décision politique la demande de
grâce
et là c'est le pouvoir régalien du chef
de l'état merci dominique cet après midi